want some meat
[Music]
on mount everest climbers are aiming for
the top of the world
but it's not just cold and extreme
height putting lives at risk
many are pushing for the peak despite a
coronavirus outbreak on the mountain
some of the teams were devastated by
coven and once the sherpas once you lose
your purpose
you can't climb nepal's hospitals are
overrun with thousands of new daily
cases
[Music]
critical oxygen cylinders and vaccines
are in short supply
as nepal's covert storm continues to
rage
is in lockdown battling its worst surge
in covet 19.
the healthcare sector is totally
overwhelmed we'll talk to the red cross
in a moment
first the government's desperate calls
for help from abroad
even the help of international tourists
a record number of whom have registered
to climb the world's most famous
mountain this year
the season's coming to an end but the
climbers could still do the people of
nepal
a huge favor
gasping for precious breath in a race
against time
these covered patients in the himalayas
are fighting for their lives
but they're among a lucky few to have
access to oxygen
a vital but increasingly scarce resource
here
a recent surge in covet 19 cases has
brought nepal's fragile health care
system to a breaking point
and oxygen supplies are running out now
the government's urging mount everest
climbers for help
all climbers at the base camp have an
ample number of oxygen cylinders
we have requested owners and operators
to bring back those empty cylinders
immediately after the completion of
their expeditions
for the benefit of the people
nepal has issued some 700 climbing
permits this season
a bid to get the mountaineering and
tourism industries back on their feet
it's estimated climbers will abandon
around three and a half thousand oxygen
bottles on the mountain
this year alone cylinders desperately
needed
in the fight against coronavirus
our government and city and our public
they have a lot of
coronavirus sickness so they have a
problem for oxygen i heard that
we have around uh seven summit tracks
have around one thousand bottle
so we can we can when the empty cylinder
is come here
we can provide this cylinder to our
government and government will be making
a refill for medical oxygen
these bottles are being prepped for a
mountain trek
if the government's plans work out they
could soon be saving lives on the ground
nitro prasad tim cena joins us from
nepal red cross
uh he's in kathmandu tell us about
what's happening
uh there because you described the
situation in india
as a horrifying preview of nepal's
future what is the situation like now
there's uh the kobe cases in nepal are
increasing day by day
and then the rate of the infection is
about 40 to 50 percent
in between 40 to 50 percent for the last
four week
and then it has also reached to the
ruler areas and then infection rate
now rural areas is increasing
so coverts spreading right throughout
the country
what about hospitals what about oxygen
what how well equipped is the country
the hospitals are overheld uh that there
is you know
all the private house people under
central government has to be resolved
full
there is no beds available no ico
available
and then no ventilators available people
are dying without
oxygen without ventilator without
without ico and people are also dying
without reaching to the hospitals in
rural areas we don't have
hospitals and then many people are dying
now in rural areas
so nepal's seeing exactly what happened
in neighboring india
but hasn't been able to equip itself in
time
what what about this what about help
from abroad help from these climbers
claiming everest bringing back
their empty oxygen tanks is there enough
help coming
yes yes many government in the for the
last three weeks the many government and
humanitarian organization has provided
oxygen cylinder
oxygen plant medical supplies means
all the marks globes and then then pp
dead body bag and the many and medicines
so the embassies and the donor agencies
and the government
from the developed countries in abroad
and also china has provided
the now and then the now situation is
not that much acute but
still we lack the 60 000 oxygen
cylinders
what about vaccine there's also been a
call from government officials for help
from abroad
as far as vaccine doses go
we don't have any vaccine right now and
then our government our primary our
prime ministers and our
presidents they have approached to the
government of asia
for the sputnik vaccines and then india
and then china
and then also uk parliament and also
united states
and then china has promised one million
but up from others no response
so now india has given 1 million um
three months before uh and then all the
one million were administered to
as the first two days but we don't have
the second doses and then if the second
dose will come we don't
we are not sure so the vaccine is very
serious issue we want vaccines
and then vaccine is the one vaccination
is the only solution
of the tree of uh optical beat so tell
us
what does nepal need to do right now to
get on top of this situation
we need we need we we need the medical
equipments and then medical
materials to equip our hospitals and
also
we need vaccines we need two things
vaccines
and then make a medical equipment
including oxygen cylinder and oxygen
plant
okay we'll have to leave it there thank
you very much for joining us and being
on the show today pleasure speaking to
you
metro prasad tim cena thank you very
much
turning now to some other stories from
the pandemic india's coronavirus
infections topped
28 million on monday with health
authorities reporting over two million
active cases
there is some good news india's daily
new infection rates continue to decline
indicating the current wave
may have already peaked china has locked
down guangzhou
after a flare-up in new covert cases
initial reports indicate the new
infections are linked to the mutation
first detected in india
health authorities are ramping up local
testing and vaccination drives to
prevent a widespread outbreak
the palestinian territories have
approved a single-dose version of
russia's sputnik vaccine
dubbed sputnik light russia's direct
investment fund is reportedly in talks
with indian manufacturers
to start reducing the jab as early as
next month for use in asian markets
and a record virus surge has hit
argentina forcing officials to suspend
the copa america football tournament
there
the chief cabinet minister said his
country tried to keep its commitment to
hosting the event but
the epidemiological situation made it
impossible
south african president cyril ramaphosa
says his country is reimposing a
stricter lockdown
amid a new surge in covert 19 cases he
says johannesburg and pretoria
are now in a third wave the surge in
cases
also highlights south africa's slow
vaccine rollout only around one and a
half percent of the country's 60 million
people have received the first dose
dw's adrian kriesch in cape town says
another lockdown
was inevitable the new restrictions
don't come as a surprise to most south
africans because
the numbers of new infections have been
increasing in the past
days and weeks and almost reached 5 000
new
cases a day at the moment this is still
far away from the peak we have seen
during the second wave in january where
we had more than 20
000 new cases a day but it is still
a reason to worry especially because the
vaccination campaign here
has been starting very slow south africa
has ordered vaccines for 75
of its population but only a fraction of
that arrived in the country and the
president here has been complaining
about that many times
before saying it is not fair that
wealthier nations have
stronger access to vaccines than
countries like south africa and also
neighboring countries
on the continent here so far only those
above the age of
60 are allowed to get the jab so this is
less than two percent of the population
at the moment those who are younger than
60 even if they have co-morbidities
don't even know if they'll be able to
get a vaccine by the end of this year
time for derek williams and a question
that could be on your mind if you're
waiting for the jab
i have a mild cold can i get vaccinated
anyway
great question um you might have been
waiting for months
for an appointment to get vaccinated and
then the day before
your nose stops up well i can tell you
from personal experience with for
example my kids pediatricians that in
general
if you're feeling even a little under
the weather on the day of a shot
then doctors really don't like to
vaccinate you for anything
in the pandemic however the cdc
in the us at least has apparently
loosened that
rule of thumb somewhat and germany's
health authority
the robot cough institute it agrees
both say that if you basically only have
the sniffles then vaccinators can go
ahead and give you
a covet 19 vaccine but if you're feeling
moderately
or more severely ill they say then you
should wait until you recover
from whatever you have to receive one as
far as i can tell
doctors and other medical experts appear
to draw the line between
mild and moderate illness largely based
on the presence
or the absence of fever so
so if you just have a runny nose or a
scratchy throat but your temperature is
normal
or close to it then you're apparently
good to go
um if you have a more acute sickness
however that involves higher fever
for germany's health authority that's
that's anything over
38 and a half degrees celsius then you
should wait to be vaccinated
but but one way or the other you need to
be tested beforehand
to to rule out the possibility that you
might have picked up
saris cov2 and and if it turns out
that what's actually causing your
cold-like symptoms
is a mild case of copit19
then the recommendation is to wait until
you've recovered fully
then at least another couple of weeks
before
rescheduling your appointment derek
williams there i'm ben fazoulen thanks
for watching stay
safe and see you again soon
you